it's just a hole in the street porn
hours in last book for hours we're gonna
be dressed up as road workers I have to
come I call I took my pants off this
happened I was riding along I was doing
something I shouldn't have been doing
riding with one leg I was on my phone
going along and I was like I need the
Google Maps where I'm going so I told I
was like should I take this street or
not and I hit a pothole and my board
just hit it my legs both likes to do
this all mine for something my thigh to
see poor your TED talk I didn't break
anything we've all been there we've all
been there and it's not a fun place did
Ben tell you what just happened he's
limping
bunch of potholes on the streets getting
so bad people are falling off one wheels
there's like a giant crater at the
beginning of the street it was a two and
a half foot tall traffic count half of
it was stuck you could even see it your
whole tire could literally fall in that
hole she'd definitely fill those
potholes out front there's a red oh you
got shot in the leg we need to go figure
out how bad this is we can figure out
what to do about it I have very little
faith in the city of Los Angeles to do
anything about this right now we live in
one of the biggest cities in the country
of I think if we call them that are
gonna come out fix the potholes yeah
that's how living in a big city works
more functional the bigger the city gets
yeah would you consider this a pothole
that's what I'm concerned about is that
these are seriously dangerous too like
cars and Hannity Tyrians take a look at
what
like not even a street and market there
straight up like this trench for me but
world war one dude yeah this is a bottle
I would classify this and that this
one's bad this one's bad let's keep
walking
look at this what are we gonna do what
is what is us coming out here and
looking at this gonna dude look at this
all the way down why is there a foam
here all the way down the street a
constant stream of cars just going over
it in parking moon's gravitational waves
that causes the concrete to Penna did
you learn that my friends latest science
video I did it's a public street the
city should repave this entire street
those guys down there claim that they
have a retail permit which allows them
to spots in a pothole but it's dangerous
as heck oh he hit it right in there
get that
[Music]
water main in there though it's got a
water man like why why isn't the city
worried about their water main just like
I think we should call the city the
reasonable person thing to do but I feel
like if they don't come in a couple of
days we just at least in front of our
building we just grab a couple of that
temporary asphalt and we fill in that
stuff so we can at least like have a
nice spot in front of our building and
safely commute over it you're on a
motorcycle you eat it right there go
flying headfirst into a into a
semi-trailer that's pulling out at the
same time which could very easily happen
you'd be dead or seriously injured and
then what do you do sue the city some
kids you did
it's just like that's the worst way to
deal with this if that's what it takes
to get fixed around here that's just
that is a that is a broken system at
that point we went out here for about
five minutes and already about five cars
have come by and almost hit this pothole
whoa looking way too close exactly
that's what this street has become this
whole part of the street can be used so
everyone's sharing the right-hand lane
of this street as a back and forth yeah
and they're building a freaking fancy
new restaurant at the end of the street
I wonder how that's going to work let's
go back and let's formulate a true plan
[Music]
yeah
this is gonna take like eight bags okay
let's just I don't I don't want the
costs of this to explode I just want to
be able to safely leave the studio on a
wheeled device without fearing that I'm
gonna fall for the first 30 feet yeah
which i think is reasonable this one
it's just a hole in the street so let's
just fill it in and move on with our
lives this is our lives we're talking
about welcome back to round 2 of the
Tournament of Champions here at corridor
where it's day and Christian and Nick
are gonna fight for the right to
represent lady expressvpn that's right
today's episode sponsor is expressvpn
and before we tell you about their
amazing VPN service we wanted to get
right down to the battle so remember
whoever wins this it's to represent lady
expressvpn
in the spring tournament which again you
don't know about the Tournament of
Champions we have four episode sponsored
members of the corridor crew will fight
to represent that sponsor in this final
spring tournament as final champion will
get to pick one person from the comments
of this video and give them 20 19
expressvpn for free that's right so if
you're already signed up or if you
signed up because of this video remember
to leave a comment because you could get
20193 who you its DVC steve do you want
to be in the in the tournament of
champions the lord square clinton time
to begin the Tournament of Champions
time to begin the Tournament of
Champions
[Applause]
[Music]
for less than seven dollars a month you
can get expressvpn with a 30 day money
back guarantee that's kind of value I
think King Sam would be in favor of
[Music]
good reason to have Express Ravana's
because recently my streaming services
have been compromised from unauthorized
emails so I use Express VPN to keep my
personal devastate I shouldn't be the
one to call to action the people I shall
be the one to call
[Music]
I was a good round you can go to
expressvpn calm / corridor crew to sign
up now if you guys are interested in
encrypting and protecting your
information on the open Internet go to
expressvpn comm / corridor crew to sign
up and find out how you can get three
months free remember there in over 94
countries they've got some of the
fastest speeds and they were rated
number one VPN service by TechRadar nic
to be proud to represent thank you lady
express to be again in the final
tournament hope I can give her name some
honor we're gonna fill these potholes
[Laughter]
it's not like they might show up and be
like wait these guys just filled it in
yeah Nick's a little concerned I think
we all are a little concerned that the
city is gonna come by we're gonna get in
trouble for this so in order to avoid
that we're gonna be dressed up as road
workers and we're even gonna go as far
as to have Sam be the union boss and
have Ren be the city councilman I mean
they'll see three legitimately like
looking Road workers working they'll
just like walk around on by and I hope
this works man this is gonna work great
dude what we're trying to do is save
lives here alright alright that's just a
lubricant for the air
[Music]
all right behind schedule working on the
ring what kind of city councilman is
this I think we need to get the city to
come you don't need a permit to mix it
just make Pitt today we got one more
little trench here to show up we got a
big one
we're way over budget I tell you open up
beautiful I got my foreign hours in last
month here what am i pouring for in
hours my porn my porn in hours I got my
porn hours in eyes but in difficult
being the councilman for sector for
another day where's my new job harder
yeah you know the old boys from sector
for they're the hardest-working ones
around I inspect the first film hey
that's good hey I'd say that's pretty
good work the light perfectly bounces
off it you can see it's a tall already a
perfectly flat surface a lot easier to
write over now you get what you pay for
well boys I think that was definitely a
success now the only question is what
other problems do you think are out
there the road to tell
[Music]
alright so the City of LA got back to me
regarding our pothole inquiry yeah it
was fast you know what this you know
what the status of it is what status is
closed
guys that case is closed by the city
because there's a sunken Department of
Water and Power Service cap in that
pothole therefore we should notify the
Department of Water and Power they're
not good nope nope they said status
closed now it's my it's our
responsibility guys to contact the
Department of Water and Power even
though the city knows about it
I'm Congress I am Tom Cruise who's heard
the wall
Tom Cruise tells you to shut the F up